[Music]
the tournament arcs truly a wonder of
battle shonen i'd say that probably some
of the best moments in battle shonen
were born out of these arcs you know
arcs that feature a lot of gripping
combat and even more emotional
backstories that get unraveled in the
course of a battle
tournament arcs also provide a good way
for the writers to showcase various
powers and capabilities
of some out of focus characters these
are the arcs when dream matches happen
these are the arcs where you suddenly
find out how badass that side character
can really be
enough of that though i'm getting really
excited to start counting down
my top 10 favorite tournament arc
battles and shonen anime but before
anything else
i've noticed that a lot of the people
watching my videos aren't subscribed yet
now that's why i'd like to encourage you
to hit that subscribe button to help the
channel out and boost its standings on
the youtube algorithm so we can grow
this community together
now let's get started we start off with
uno
versus real
in contrast to the long gritty wars that
tournament fighters wage
this is a comparatively short fight
shorter doesn't necessarily mean worse
though and while lacking the impact that
those long dramatic fights do this
battle does show a great exchange
made all the more enticing thanks to the
anime team's work on the adaptation
it's a nifty exchange of counters
between magical abilities
you know and real decide to push the
tempo to the next level unleashing their
trump cards while uno seems to have the
upper hand in the exchange
real seems to just have the perfect
counter for it with their magical blast
stalemating
the fight just ends yep real destroys
his own crystal to end the match an
interesting thing here is that we're
lost because of his own power here
it's a pretty nice fight and while i
wanted more of a conclusive finish i
think that the twist is quite cool and
helps protect both combatants from
future battles
next we go to one of the big
up-and-coming hits in the shonen scene
jiu-jitsu kaizen
has been getting a lot of traction due
to the sheer impact of the rule of call
i mean come on with so many flashy
battles and mappa's amazing art and
animation team all over it i wasn't
surprised to see jujitsu kaizen be so
well received i'm also not surprised
that we're getting a fight from the
series as a representative when i
decided to make a top tournament
fights list our rep this time is panda
vs mekamaru when i first read the scene
in the manga
i had some really high expectations but
those were just blown away when i saw
how amazing the fight looks in anime
format for first time watchers
i felt that this could seem a little bit
weird actually i mean only in tekken
with a panda fighting a mechanical
woodman thing makes sense
however all those worries would be
flushed away the moment you see how
impactful the attacks on the tempo
swings in the fight became in animated
format
largely thanks to mapper magic for those
not watching jiu jitsu kaizen this could
serve as a benchmark of what you can
expect out of this series
and you are missing out by not watching
it
next is eugero versus kakugaio from baki
for as long as i knew him i've always
seen eugero to be the ultimate last boss
in baki that much is obvious but unlike
a lot of other supposed end game
villains in anime yujiro just seems too
overpowered all the way through i can't
see any [ __ ] in his armor and he's just
an unstoppable force who simply stomps
and bulldozes his way through fighting
tournaments
until though he ran into kakukayo make
no mistake i never thought that yu jiro
would lose this fight but garco gaiu had
a lot of people in the first half by
backing the former into a corner a first
half that consists of just a few seconds
but he did make eugero second thing his
relentless assault for a moment
flashy techniques and all eugero versus
gaku gaiu
is basically a glorified stomp that
doesn't make it any less entertaining
in fact i'd say that this sudden twist
of garco gaio seemingly having a chance
if even just for a split second
makes the fight worth the watch
up next we have an entry from pokemon
that's right did you know that once upon
a time
pokemon transcended its identity as the
morning kids show that everyone knows
and turned full shonen there's a reason
why the carlos saga had been touted as
one of the best in the show's storied
run a far cry from the highly criticized
unova arc people also remember it for
being the closest ash has been to a
championship before finally winning it a
couple of years back along the way we
got treated to a lot of crazy fights
mostly involving grey ninja's anime
exclusive form and the most memorable of
them for me was the fight against mega
sceptile i haven't been this excited for
a pokemon fight in a while and the
battle between the two pokemon lived up
to the building even with a type
disadvantage you have ash and
grainninger pulling through in a
climactic battle with quality that
people typically don't know the pokemon
anime for
overall i think that if there's a fight
to convince anyone to check out some
pokemon anime episodes for this
would definitely be one of them
[Music]
being a boxing anime and all it's no
surprise that hajime no ippo
finds its way to the list it's
representative this time
ippo versus sendo
great rivalry starts somewhere and for
those who love the rivalry between ippo
and sendo you can see the route starts
somewhere in the rookie king tournament
there's a lot of anticipation entering
the fight as we just saw ippo deal with
some clowns in his mind entering the
fight perhaps the psychological
disadvantage would prove to be his
undoing
not that it seemed to affect the outcome
of the fight when all said and done
though and after the two go at each
other in a grueling war hippo manages to
land decisive blow after another
resulting in the match ending with a
shocking twist it gave us one of the
most iconic visuals in early hajime no
ippo with the unconscious
sendo down but not completely out of it
he looked extremely strong in defeat
and i think the fight just further
proves how much of a badass he is i
probably don't need to tell you this
anymore but this fight would soon lead
to a second round down the line their
duel in the lollapalooza arc ended up
being one of my favorite fights in the
series
before we move on to the next entry on
the list i'd like to take this time to
thank today's sponsors
expressvpn when trying to watch anime
legally
you often find yourself blocked by
region logs i mean we can't have
everything now can we right
if you live somewhere that's not on the
priority list for licensing companies
like i do these can end up being very
annoying however i managed to find a way
around that hurdle thanks to our best
friend here expressvpn
i use it to watch my favorite anime
because my region doesn't support a lot
of the cool shows with such thrilling
fight scenes that we just went over all
i had to do was open up
expressvpn and select the united states
server and boom
now i can watch hunter hunter like
dozens of other anime on netflix
for its cheap subscription price you get
some top notch quality service
and the fastest speeds available for any
vpn software in town don't wait any
further before taking this amazing
package that i provide for you
three months of expressvpn for free
that's right for free all you have to do
is visit the link expressvpn.com
vinnie tube or click the link in the
description box below now
back to the show
goku vs jiren pretty much epitomizes
what dragon balls been known for
explosions insane powers after another
impeccable guts and the will to win many
consider the honorable jiren to be one
of the strongest mortals in the dragon
ball super universe so what happens when
he goes all out against the protagonist
who knows no quit
some dragon ball goodness that's what
even with goku's multiple power-ups he
still finds himself on the ropes and on
the brink of defeat
as we know from goku defeat only serves
as further motivation to go beyond his
limits it's an overwhelming display of
power that dragon ball popularized and
it's great the newer generations of fans
can enjoy the insanity thanks to dragon
ball super
in fourth place is a plucky hero versus
an overwhelming force fight
in gone versus hisoka
heaven's arena in hunter hunter has had
its fair share of noteworthy moments and
i'm positive that you fans remember that
it also brought us one of the best
tournament fights in the entire series
gone vs hisoka by far one of the best
fights in the series as a whole i mean
we can argue that there are battles with
more intensity and emotional impact for
who doesn't like an underdog fight
especially one pitting our idealistic
spark plug against one of the most
sadistic villains anime's ever seen gone
versus hisoka was a fight where i just
couldn't help but root for gone
despite the huge disadvantage he's going
up against i can't imagine a scenario
wherein gon pulls out a win but i can't
certainly see a tie or an honorable loss
and that's really what happened the
fight shows off the combatants creative
arsenals and provides a good character
development checkpoint for our hero
if you're a person looking to get into
hunter hunter but want to just skim
through the sagas and all make sure you
don't skip this specific fight for
heaven's arena arc
seriously
what's up
if you ask me who deku's biggest rival
in the series is i'll answer bakugo
without hesitation nonetheless todoroki
also makes one good secondary rival a
calm and melancholic foil to the
boisterous bakugo i could talk about the
fight
but i want to highlight the character
development in this fight more this
fight
is the highlight for todoroki's
character arc early on and despite the
fight being awesome and all with its
twists and turns i still find it
secondary even in defeat
deku has managed to grab the greatest
victory of them all saving todoroki and
allowing him to start accepting the
potential that he shunned for so long
this is a fight that just keeps getting
better and better the more you watch it
perhaps the anime team blowing a
season's worth of budget on a fight has
something to do with it adding to the
context and the character stakes in this
fight
talk about an about face in the
narrative too my first time watching i
expected deku to win
and move on to settle things with bakugo
but looks like we got denied that match
nonetheless when it's all said and done
i did like the direction the story went
to
let's travel back in time again for our
second place fight
yusuke vs toguro
[Music]
how can we have a top tournament fight
list without talking about probably the
most remembered tournament arc in anime
history the dark tournament arc from yu
yu hakusho i even dare say that it's the
magic of the dark tournament arc that
paved the way for the newer generations
of anime and their own spins on
tournament arcs of course the trademark
fight of the ark is the emotional
slugfest between yusuke and toguro in
terms of the art
i don't think that this fight holds up
that much to the best of modern anime
but the emotion is still there it's
still an exciting fight through and
through and as yusuke tries to dig deep
into his bag of tricks he keeps getting
rammed into a brick wall of power that
is toguro and his ever increasing
percentages i know it's not marketed as
an underdog fight as much as some of its
kin but this fight i can say
is despair personified for any shounen
hero in terms of suspense
this fight has to be up there you know
that yusuke has to win somehow but with
each passing moment i just grew more and
more unsure of how our hero would pull
it off seriously how are you going to
put a stop to the personification of the
this is not even my final form meme
at the very top of the list is one of
the best underdog fights in all of anime
rockley versus gara there are lots of
memorable moments in naruto's tuning
exam arc among the numerous highlights
that you can dig from this treasure of
an arc is probably one of the best
fights in the series that's really aged
beautifully
rockley versus gara in one corner you
have the stoic killer and arc boss
material gala
one look and you immediately get the
impression that this is the kind of
character
who'd be left for naruto to defeat at
the end of the arc in the other corner
is comedy mainstay rock lee who's no
slouch but has yet to prove himself to
be a big threat it should be a stomp to
push gara and have him move on right
no rockley more than puts up a fight
pushing gara to the defensive and
overwhelming him it's not even the
standard
job of five seconds of offense before
getting destroyed rockley
simply spends a lot of the fight
outright pummeling and destroying gara
of course given character
hierarchy that effort doesn't stick and
gara stands tall at the end but you
can't deny that the story did a great
job of making it seem that lee had a
legitimate chance
the mystique of ghana being that scary
unbeatable force was gone and the deed
was done by rockley of all people
in a super badass showing that makes
this my number one pick for best
tournament fight in anime
that more or less wraps up this list and
i want to ask you this question do you
think the rock lee versus gara deserves
the top spot i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this so head off to the
comments section if you want to share
your opinions
special thanks to zodiac 15 and all
other patreons for making this video
possible
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video expressvpn
bypass all those pesky region locks and
even browse sites not available in your
region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now for
now that's got to do it and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you